iran being weeks away from having full
fuel to power atomic bomb
uh state department warns iran will have
enough uh fissile material enriched to
weapon great capacity in weeks not
months a senator a senior state
department official said monday
following the conclusion of another
round of indirect talks with iran and
world powers in vienna following 10
months of negotiations the state
department department says diplomacy
diplomacy will cease in the coming weeks
whether iran takes a deal or not this is
because the biden administration
assesses that iran's nuclear program
will have become so advanced that
re-entering the 2015 nuclear accord will
provide no benefits to u.s and global
national security in the years since
trump withdrew from the deal iran has
enriched uranium the key component and a
bomb so extremely high levels of purity
negotiations are paused as iranian
diplomats travel back to tehran to
consult with the hardline ruling
government if iran takes the deal
virtually all u.s sanctions imposed by
trump administration will evaporate
giving the regime access to billions of
dollars of cash
is that a concern to you with what's
going on there with iran i mean it is
but i also think you know this is kind
of to adam's question of of involvement
is that you you really have to decide
do we want them or are we okay with them
having this or are we not
if the answer is is we're not and we
need to stop it then as a country you
have to decide we will do what is
necessary to prevent that whatever that
is right is that if it's if it's that
red line like hey iran cannot have
the capability to have any nuclear
capacity whatsoever
if that means that that we carpet bomb
you know the the facilities we you know
what whatever it takes
intelligence-based uh
you know wise
is that that's what you do you know no
again no different than afghanistan iraq
world war ii whatever is is that you
know to me the cat and mouse aspect of
the negotiations and and the accords and
the peace deals and the cash and and all
these other things are kind of a
distraction
in that you just have to ask yourself
are we going to be
uh are we going to sit on the sideline
while they do it or not now whether or
not we we take action that that's a
whole another conversation but i think
as a country there needs to be a
decision one way or another and you just
do whatever here's my question how do we
know how do we even know that this is
taking place right now like how why is
how do we know that iran is
weeks away from having fuel to fuel a
power atomic bomb how do we know that
what insider information is yvonne iran
leaking to us they're not going to leak
anything to the states i mean so this is
where you know
i'll be careful in how i tread on on
what i say but
there there are intelligence assets that
that provide the capabilities through a
number of resources and that's
electronic human uh you know traditional
spying uh you know communications
intelligence etc
uh all kind of coupled together to to
make determinations and assessments like
that uh but that's really all how deep
are we as uh
and i'm gonna go a little bit deeper
you you to hear what you're gonna say
about this
how deep is
u.s whether you want to put cia or you
know whatever you want to call it in
iran
to
constantly gather intel and send it to
us are we pretty involved heavily there
or it's mild
i i would say uh
again not having um maybe as intimate
not as knowledge as maybe you would
assume but what i do know is is just
again from having you know a lot of
friends that do do things like that and
and having worked in that capacity is
that there are always people involved in
in all of the kind of big actors and
that's in every one of those capacities
that i just mentioned it's signal
intelligence it's
communications it's human it's all of
those things and so
you know the the united states has has
this map of okay here are all the the
major concerns and then they dedicate
assets based on
the same way say an er doctor would
triage an emergency room after an
accident is that this is the biggest
threat this you know and they're they're
allocating resources based on that so
without a doubt there is is moderate um
you know to to heavy involvement in uh
every capacity that that we have the
ability to be involved in in that
country specifically and also don't
forget i mean our our position keeps
changing whether it was the uh biden who
led the charge on the iran nuclear deal
uh trump pulled out you know now biden
is getting back in it whatever it is but
there's one thing that has not wavered
and that's israel yeah
our stance has changed here in the
united states israel is
dead set on iran not being a nuclear
power so whether that's them taking out
scientists taking out plants like they
are not playing around they do not want
iran to have this nuclear power yeah i
mean it's a much bigger threat to them
than it is to us
yeah i mean yeah they're right obviously
the the iranian rhetoric is we're going
to wipe them off the map they don't want
israel to exist yeah i mean no different
than if uh you know say china built a
an air force base in in tijuana right
like we're going to be a lot more
bent about that than israel is because
it's right there you know or if we're in
cuba
russia like that or you know russia has
a
um you know an an amphibious assault
group or an aircraft carrier
uh you know 30 miles off the coast of
california you know is israel gonna
say yeah that's messed up and that we
don't think they should do that or
whatever probably are they going to be
as worried about it as we are absolutely
not you know geographically the united
states has to just be
i mean we're very lucky that we're not
in the middle of all this nonsense in
the middle east eurasia anything like
that yeah i mean geographically it
certainly uh
is at our advantage i will say the more
technologically advanced the human race
becomes the less that matters
whether it's cyber attacks or satellite
stuff [ __ ] coming you know lasers from
outer space type stuff
the the more and more capable human
beings become from from a technology
standpoint it's not going to matter as
much it already doesn't i mean china has
the ability to do what they do
as well as russia i mean they've they've
made our lives uh pretty difficult over
the last decade both of them from
without ever even having to come here
you know so
it still plays a role i'd still
i'd still rather have a geographical
advantage than not
um you know but that that gap is
shortening year after year so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye
[Music]